we're gonna move past that yes and kick
things off with something much happier
the sounds of Carlos Santana's guitar
the Rock and Roll Hall of Famer and
music icon is back and continuing his
10th year of residency at the House of
Blues as he performs his show and it's
number 301 wow our senior producer
Natalia mountainito sat down with a
headliner to chat about his shows his
creative process musical influences and
more
[Music]
he's been rocking the stage for over
half a century and there's no signs of
stopping Carlos Santana is returning to
his residency at the House of Blues
right here in Las Vegas to jolt his fans
with one-of-a-kind musical experience
they can expect to be jolted you know
it's like when you when you get a heart
attack and they jolt you and they bring
you back
thank you
we jolt people out of
boredom at a complacency out of fear and
a lack of self-worth we jolt people into
a place of frequency people listen to
Santana they go feeling Priceless
Santana's music is just that Priceless
it is a mixture of high energy sounds
influenced by rhythms from all over the
world it's important for me as a
musician but as a person to keep
everything
fresh new authentic
and uh and true for this music icon
creating every note and every song comes
with a purpose along with that special
creative process it all starts with me
with taking a deep breath
and feeling the epicenter of your heart
it's important for me to feel what
you're feeling
when you feel what you're feeling you're
able to convince people that you're
going to transport and transport them
into a place of wondered men and to a
place where
they're getting more than they paid for
and just in case you were contemplating
on whether or not you should go and see
a Carlos Santana show this might change
your mind it's important for me as a
musician and as a person
to utilize the music to rescue people
[Music]
that was so good you can spend an
intimate evening with Santana listening
to his Greatest Hits live at the House
of Blues starting tonight with several
dates throughout the year for tickets
and more information visit House of
Blues